now coming together to create a better
workplace is what's mobilizing one local
Starbucks to unionize thank you for
staying with us at 4 30 I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Christian casadas well if
achieved it would become the first here
in the state of Nevada well tonight one
local coffee shop owner speaks out if
this step is the best move
I like to see people the same way I like
to be here
has been working at this Las Vegas
coffee shop on Maryland Parkway and
Flamingo for the past two years having a
small staff he says helps minimize
problems in the workplace it's easier
for me and it's easier for a small
business to hear their employees but I
feel like as you get bigger with a
business it's easier to lose sight and
lose focus a similar Focus for the
Starbucks employees off Rainbow and Okie
who submitted this letter to the
company's CEO about intent to unionize
claiming they have not been treated as
partners and employees have no respect
or voice in the workplace for a
corporation that big I think it might be
necessary if um if your employees and
your staff are having issues where
they're not being heard Tiffany Biscoe
owns this and other coffee shops across
the valley she says her company does
things to enrich the culture like
outings and events while unions are
great she says it's all about the
connection with the worker at that point
as a business owner I would just be
asking what more can I do employee would
have more rights um and and you know the
employer has rights as well Michael
nekavoyamaya is a labor attorney in
southern Nevada although he says each
case is different unionizing is a
process here you go for this employee he
prefers the personal benefits of being
in a small business I love loved it
every moment of it because like I can be
heard